child
my phone
just make sure
the audio is working
you just said that i'm alive ew
oh well
everybody does it
okay hold on
quite
all right guys sorry about that
grossness
okay nobody's watching anyways
shh
check check
okay guys is the audio okay
i'm gonna grab
you know i didn't want you to eat on the
live you have to hold the mic that's why
we're sitting on the couch
child
i feel like they could hurt hear me
quite well
i think so actually i was surprised how
well
okay guys tell me how the audio is can
you hear the washer in the background
the dryer
okay
okay we sit like this i mean like look
at each other and be like i love you
you're the best sister in the world
okay wait
guys all right let me know in the chat
guys how was the audio
nice and clear what what's nice and
clear me and me eva
your mom
okay wait
let me see how center let's make this a
little higher
okay let's see
they said they can't hear the dryer
surprisingly
okay
am i going to get belated about my
potential career choices
no that was yesterday
today i'll get berated about other
opinions
okay
is there anything off limits i can't ask
you on camera i don't want to get
cancelled
i'm like
so nothing you can get cancelled for but
you're not big enough for them to cancel
you i can hear the driver how could they
cancel
how could not
i always said they can hear the dryer
now
is that one's fast spin
well now it's done
okay i think
let me know if it's so bad it's like
distracting
okay
um
okay back to business
should i have to put the lights on us
like good lighting
how important do you think that is
what do you do
[Laughter]
[Music]
whatever we'll just leave it what did we
end up ordering last night we had sushi
today last night today
yeah
you're gonna want to put the mic a
little closer to you
i feel like they can hear me can you
guys hear me
i really don't like that you can see the
chat
i think you should give me your phone
i
see
shane said it's fine
shane
okay tell me this
am i your favorite sister no
am i your smartest sister no am i your
coolest sister no am i
am i your most interesting sister no
who's more interesting than me
me
you can't pick yourself
i live in london
mary lives in texas might as well be the
same thing
oh my god okay
tell me this
it's hard to talk about dating on my
podcast when you have no dating
experience
and keep it that way she's 17
17.
should i turn off the dryer it's kind of
annoying me
i feel like you're just you just need to
zone it out okay you're right
what was your favorite part about
growing up with me
i didn't really grow up with you you
don't remember it i do
i took you on girls nights
well that wasn't wasted your time
you don't remember me taking you
rollerblading
i remember rollerblading the house with
everybody no i took you to like a roller
skating rink
yeah i don't remember that
you guys see this why spend time with
your siblings because
yeah seriously why spend time with your
siblings and i'm going home
did you enjoy this trip
are you happy you came
i mean yeah it was really fun to go to
school actually that's
okay we're like every day when we wake
up we're like i'm not proud of us i'm
like huh
i think we did well don't tell them what
happened don't tell them this is
embarrassing now you might have to turn
off the dryer i think we should turn off
the dryer okay
can i eat my sushi while you do that
guys she wouldn't let me eat my sushi
oh my gosh the dryers here are so loud
they're not like this in the u.s
it might just be because you have a
small little cheap one
that's stuck in between cabinets here
they don't have dryers though
like they're not common
and you see my tick tock followers are
hating me now
no yeah they're like switching because i
started putting this content on my tick
tock
they'll say they say let me let me read
you some of the comments
um
they're like
um
[Music]
they're saying i'm fat phobic and
misogynist
is that crazy
do you think i'm misogynistic
no i just think you're very very
opinionated
yeah
you think i hate women
i think i hate
that's pretty much it they just say i
hate women
it's kind of nuts
like i have four sisters
[Music]
i try to hang out with them they don't
always hang out with me but
first off you live in london how are we
supposed to hang out with you oh my gosh
even when i was home you guys did not
want to hang out i'm a busy person
i don't know but amelia probably just
didn't want to hang out but i'm a busy
person you always wanted me to like go
do the horse thing every time i'd be
like you want to hang out and then you'd
be like come do the horses
because that's everything i had to do
every time i wanted like you were like
you want to hang out like i have to go
to my horses you can come with me and
you're like
no thanks so technically you didn't want
to hang out with me
well yes i don't want to do the horses
they also say do you think i'm
brainwashed
i feel like everybody's brainwashed they
say that i'm brainwashed on tick tock
i think everybody's brainwashed in their
own special way
what do you mean
like that's how we learn things that we
get brainwashed by people
that's true i mean it's all like picking
and choosing because there are very few
people with like a completely original
idea
hold on mom's calling let's see
hey mom
hi hannah how are you i'm good how are
you
i'm good
i'm tired
okay happy mother's day in england
apparently we there's two different
mother's days
oh that's weird yeah someone's yeah
happy it's mother's day in england
that's interesting i didn't know that
well i'm doing a show so i have to go
okay
all right love you bye
what if i started talking [ __ ] about you
be like mom let's talk [ __ ] about eva
your opinions and eva's beliefs
that'd be a good show i'd say that
i really want to like brainwash eva
[Laughter]
actually she told me if i can turn
amelia into a republican she'd send me
her
i said mom i can't promise that but i
can make her help me with republican
content
this isn't even really republican though
this is like pro-man
i feel like republicans are more men
like more men than they are a woman
that's why
well it's more like i put it
because a lot of the people that follow
me are like more left leaning but it's
just like the woke stuff is
more like
women are right no matter what choices
they make
and i just don't like it when people
can't own up to bad decisions that's
what bothers me
and women do that more than men in my
opinion
you think that's misogynistic
no
that's just part of if anything is part
of women's rights do you want everybody
to
be accountable
yeah i just think women like aren't like
i don't think it's fair how like a guy
if he knocks up
like if a guy knocks up someone
that's super like
or if a girl gets knocked up by someone
super rich i don't think that should be
like a check
i still think a man should have to pay
child support
because
like yes a woman can do a lot about
being pregnant but also a man still had
to take a part of it he didn't take
proper precautions like she didn't take
proper production do you think though
because a girl could have an abortion
that a man should like if he says i
don't want this kid
i'm not signing off on it
can i like can he wave all rights before
they're born because a woman can do that
and a man can't so it's like equal
because if a woman gets pregnant and the
man says please have the kid please
please whatever like she's still she
it's her choice he doesn't get a say in
the abortion so if it's the other way
around and a man gets a girl pregnant
and he wants her to abort it and she
says no do you think he has the right to
like waive financial rights
i think he could go to court after the
child is born and work on it that way
but i don't think because some people
like i personally believe in pro-choice
but some people don't believe in that
like that's
in the people who believe in pro-life
they believe that it's a life as soon as
it's created so it's like you can't kill
a child after it's created just because
you don't
no longer want it
no i know but i'm saying like i agree
with you
but i'm saying like he wouldn't kill it
he would wave financial responsibility
so he would say before the baby's born
he would say i don't want that like
because a girl can do that she can
remove all responsibility of the kids
she can choose adoption
if she wants to have the kid she doesn't
believe in it she can give it up
and wave responsibility that way
she can also wave responsibility by
having an abortion
or by having it in keeping it and
getting child support
but there's no way that the man can get
rid of the responsibility
do you think that's fair
i think that it has to be
no i see what you're saying yeah you see
but i also think that
like too many men would just wave rights
for when they are being responsible
there has to be some like
limitations to it
yeah no i can see that but
it's weird because i'm actually very
much like you should be responsible for
your own choices so i do think it's the
guy's fault for not wearing a condom
during sex
but then you get like it's just getting
to the point where like girls are are
doing like why is drake putting hot
sauce in his condoms
did you hear about that
no that's kind of you didn't hear about
that i don't follow drake
so drake
like um
yeah
but you just want it to be like yeah
yeah so drake had kept having girls like
trying to have his kid right
and so oh yeah no i did here yeah so
they couldn't like take it yeah and so
it's like why like that should be
illegal like why can girls do that i
think it is illegal to take it i don't i
i don't think so why did she feel
comfortable going to court and trying to
sue him over it
i don't think there's any law that says
that's illegal
i should try to think of the term have
you ever watched jane the virgin
yeah because luisa got sued for um
whatever
the beginning i think it's the same
thing
yeah it's just um it's that someone in
the comments said the court doesn't
allow a man to do that after the baby's
born
i don't know i just like that's what
makes me mad like that's why i do what i
do is because it's not even like a
republican thing like to me it's just
like i don't like it when shit's not
equal
and like to me like that's not equal
that makes sense
yeah like because even drake he's doing
everything right and he could still get
a girl pregnant
like isn't that crazy like he did
everything right
wore the condom
you know that'd be a case that huge
should be allowed to wave financial
rights yeah
but like you but i'm saying like you
might not even know because the girl can
like i i've heard of girls telling guys
that she's on birth control and just
like she's not
yeah that's what i mean that there has
to be like some like level where they
can and can't wait financial rights i
think that a guy
if we're gonna give girls the power to
have an abortion like i think i should
have the power to have way of financial
responsibility
i don't believe in abortion so if it was
up to me like that would be illegal but
i don't see that happening
so
texas is being crazy right now
you call it crazy i call it
i call it
you what i mean like i feel like
like if we're gonna give
like it should just be equal because
women can wave the responsibility i
think like
men
should be able to too you know
yeah i still think there should be some
limitations on it like if a man is just
going around being irresponsible yeah
but if it's just like if it's the woman
being irresponsible then
like the guy that had 75 kids in
kentucky
like that like the guy trying to hold it
a little closer like look how close mine
is you're just not being fun
you can switch mics if you want this is
a little shorter
i just got a setup
but
um
oh my gosh i have a new member thank you
jeremy for becoming a new member also
guys if you want to send donations all
donations will be used for a new camera
at the end of the month
um i'm trying to save up i'm like 300
away from the nicer camera
um that's what i'm saving for if if i
don't get it like i'm still getting a
different camera it's just not going to
be the one that i was
like looking for
okay do you think okay you're young are
you in birth control
no
no i mean your sister was at
gabrielle yeah she was at 16. barely
even barely gabriel barely took it if
she had the iud i think yeah she's not
you d but that's like i mean i thought
you meant like the pill no no but you
don't need an iuds i would really
effective i would never get birth
control like an iud or
um
and or like the thing in your arm all of
it's awful
that's what do you think because you're
a teenager do you think that they
properly educate you know the side
effects of birth do you think they're
kind of eager to put you on it no a lot
of doctors are do you know like birth
control has long term side effects like
a lot of it does
and the same thing with like you can
actually sue a doctor if they don't tell
you like how your id iud is putting in
getting put in because you use cervical
clamps that actually aren't clamps
they're like spikes that they like like
they pierce your cervix to open it so
you can actually sue them for like
whatever because
what does that mean you can look up like
the like the thing that it's like a
clamp but it's like like claw
and it
you know it's like
you can actually sue a doctor for it
wait what does it do something to you it
just open it not like long term but like
it it pierces you to open your cervix to
get the iud in
they also don't like do anesthesia or
anything
no i had an iud for like a year but i
got it taken out
yeah
but like
gabriel like you could see the
difference with gabrielle like
emotionally too with her iud
and she would be on her period for like
months at a time does she still have it
yeah i think so
okay like she sometimes gets her period
for like three or four months it's hard
because you don't want an unplanned
pregnancy i know that's why it's like so
i understand but like like it changes
the type of partners you're attracted to
did you know that
i'm not surprised so like there are
cases where girls went on birth control
really young and they believed like they
thought they were gay
and then they went off of birth control
and they're like oh i'm not gay
because
oh it spans yeah it might just be there
we go um
because you're more attracted to
feminine traits
when you're on birth control
isn't that they say something mean what
no they said a claw in an iud you gross
sounds painful
um
but
isn't that crazy though like it's
literally changes the type of people
you're attracted to
yeah
not surprised though
so like
like and then there's cases where girls
go off birth control and they're not
attracted to their husbands because they
met him on birth control
that's so sad that's why i like i i
really haven't been on it a lot i was on
it
for maybe like two or three years but
then i went off it
i also just feel like birth control is
used for a lot of things when it doesn't
need to be
like i have a friend who's on birth
control for her acne
yeah i agree and like i'm just like i
feel like there's other like don't get
me wrong if you tried a lot but like i
feel like you got to keep trying instead
of just
getting thrown at birth control because
birth control also like breaks down your
uterine lining and it makes it thinner
over time if you're on it for too long
really it can make it harder for you to
get pregnant in the future yeah that's
why i stopped because i just
my life like i've just always been
really driven and like i've always been
like
i've just felt like because of sports
and because of what i'm interested in
i might like kids might be a later than
i'd ideally want
yeah like i think biologically like i'd
want to be married and have kids now but
it's just with sports and stuff it isn't
how it worked out
that's gross what the kids no you could
be married i could be married i wish i
was married i wanted to meet my husband
you're old enough to be
i know
i wanted to meet my husband in college
actually i could have picked it
yeah
do you think that women
like okay because you're a younger
generation
and i feel like my generation really
wasn't taught the value of sex
like outside of just like
um like like i think that as a girl like
sex is the most valuable thing you can
like give to a guy
do you think that like as women were
really taught that
i think if anything we're taught to like
it's weird because we're all like yes
like we're taught that like to keep over
especially going to a catholic school
like you're just taught to be a virgin
basically like either you're a virgin or
you're married there's no in between
well it's kind of hard because
i remember listening to like the
catholic speakers at school
and all the girls would be like well i
did all this stuff and i still found my
husband
i was like okay well then why do i
like i wasn't as crazy as like that ever
did you have christina and jason everett
huh okay i don't this um this christian
catholic couple or whatever that came to
this is the one in the that video that
you watched in like eighth grade yeah
yeah where it's like the girls like i
got ran through but i still follow us
and then another talking about like we
don't use sex or pleasure we do sex for
kids or whatever we do it on like on a
schedule yeah and that's not like honest
either i think no i i hate to i hate to
say it but despite what the church
teaches you
sex is also for pleasure not just for
kids but here's the problem though is
they don't teach you like i think as a
girl it's more effective to like if i
knew
you know like you're less you're seen as
less valuable to guys the more people
like if you have sex with a lot of
people
yeah and i don't think that's like a fun
reality but it's just like true
you know what i mean like
like no guy wants to wife up a hoe
yeah like and it's it's not like fun
like it's not fun that guys get to do
this and we don't but like
that that's in my like that's just how
men view it
because there's biological like like
because
historically men wanted to ensure
paternity
and um a girl that slept around a lot
they didn't know who that was the if
that was like their kid does that make
sense
yeah does that make sense or okay
um so
but like they can't turn that off you
know like there's biological reasons do
you think that's true or not true like
nowadays that guy's just like like guys
who don't want to date girls that have
slept around with a lot of people do you
think that's true
yeah
okay do you feel like you learned that
by talking to guys by just watching or
like i just feel like being in the world
because you're especially like tick-tock
and stuff
okay like like
i go to a catholic school no guys or
girls in my school are hoes like
not really really yeah especially with
coven people like just because like
kova took away the whole year like when
you're like in high school long enough
that you're just like guys
or adults like
are most of your friends virgins
yeah i think so really okay
yeah
and when i graduated high school i'd say
like maybe half of mine were
i'd say like 75 percent because i was a
virgin until i was when do you think do
you know when i lost my virginity
it was like college to that one guy
who
you told me about in the portillo's
parking lot
i don't know if it was the same guy but
it was like sophomore year college i
think for you yeah it was yeah
though the guy i told you about she
always brings up the story where i guess
i told her about a guy that kissed me
when he was drunk
you said cost her but i just assumed
drunk okay yeah i told her about this
guy but i never slept with him or did
anything with him he just i thought he
liked me but he was just drunk my bad
[Laughter]
i don't know man i was like i was like
eight and i was like guys
what's my sister doing to me right now i
don't think you were eight were you if i
was
no i was definitely older than that
because i was
you picked me from volleyball i think so
i i had to be at least 12. i think i was
bummed
then you after that whole thing you told
me like don't tell anybody about this
but also i hate your age group you guys
are just the most annoying age group
like don't tell anybody but like i hate
your age group i'm like this is like an
invitation to tell everybody
i mean i didn't tell anybody until like
i was older i was like hey i remember
this and you're like no and i was like
hannah no the more you talked about it i
was like i think this was a guy
yeah he stopped talking to me because i
wouldn't sleep with him
he was like no sex
on to the next one
but
no i was no i was but the crazy thing is
i was old like i was one of the last
girls in my age group for school to like
be a virgin like i was late
i feel like that's another thing is that
people tell us to protect your virginity
but also if you're a virgin too late in
life
i was 20. i was 20
yeah
or maybe 19 i don't know
19 or 20. i was a sophomore in college
but
well okay i think though
like
because the problem here's the problem
though because
if you in college you're not dating guys
that are like trying to get married you
know like if you're trying to get
married like virginity is something like
very valuable to men but the problem is
like
you have to date older to like get that
guys that value that
but at the same time
a lot of guys i don't know because then
i also talk to guys that say they don't
want a virgin
so
it's kind of like
i don't know it's like a double but you
know what you're okay did you know if
you're a virgin and you get married what
percent chance you have of being in a
happy marriage
i actually do know this my priest said
this i just don't remember it was like
because like i think divorce rates were
like 50 now or maybe a little bit higher
but then he was like saying that like if
you're virgins when you get go into
marriage it's like 70
like success rate yeah but if you live
if you're both virgins going in and you
guys live in separate houses instead of
living together then your divorce rate
is like or your chances of staying
together like 95 and i'm like that
defeats the whole no he was saying like
all these things and like the whole
purpose of getting married is to like
the church even says one union so why
would you live in two houses
yeah okay i don't get the houses but
he's right about the 70 and you know
what it drops to if you've had sex with
more than like five people
probably like 80 is like divorce rate
it's no it's like a 30 chance of being a
happy marriage
so you go from 70
what
like so so i don't know what the stat is
for like divorce rate or whatever but
this is percent your percent chance of
being in a marriage you would rate as
like very happy
so it goes from like 70 to 30.
isn't that crazy
because i guess like the more it's like
harder for girls to like bond the more
people that they like slept with because
that's the one thing i'll tell you when
i lost my virginity like
i didn't realize how attached i would
get to that guy like i got so attached
you told me that but i also talked to
other people who told me that they
didn't
like that's why i'm like like no i i i
could see why you would get attached
because like that's like
i feel like especially going to catholic
school it's considered such a big thing
but like there's other people who are
just like whatever i think some girls
it's like that because they weren't
really that attracted to the guy
that's my take on it like all the girls
that i know that have said that like
weren't really that attracted to him he
was just kind of like there at the time
and they moved on to like bigger and
better things but i think like what they
say is the reason
it's like hard if your husband's not the
best sex of your life
because then you'll always want like the
other guy i guess and so the more people
you have sex with like the less likely
it is does that make sense yeah
and i guess the more people you you kind
of get more traumatized like look at me
right
like my like how much did my last like
boyfriend traumatize me
you don't have to like i mean you like
flood the country
okay
don't worry like i don't want to like
give specifics
but even like even like our other
siblings right like the more
relationships you go through the more
like traumatized you are our family
doesn't date very much though that's
kind of funny to me but like
maybe we just really are not the most
attractive people
i mean i'm just saying look at austin's
chin
awesome
you know why it's like that right
you know he hates mom so like mom hates
beards so he leaves it and then once he
goes back home mom he shaves it no
austin
um our family doesn't date much i feel
like when we do date we date really
seriously yeah that's what i mean is
that like like i've never met any like
i'm sure austin dated other people
before melissa there was one like girl
he brought to now there's two girls who
brought to the house yeah but none that
like none that are memorable enough and
like like even if it's like he didn't
date them for long enough for me to even
see them probably more than once or
twice
no
the oh my god no like even gabrielle's
first relationship that lasted like two
years
yeah and then the other one lasted like
a year
right i think a little bit less than
that
but like still like it wasn't like just
like a fling
no and then mine
was like and then you never met the guy
from college but that went on for like
years i just
yeah
yeah but that also doesn't sound like it
was a really serious relationship no it
wasn't so like it was to me it was one
side
it was one one way
oh
this oldest sibling
how old 100 i guess like 35. well mary
is yeah but i don't know mary's age
because mary's like 47 i think or no the
two old
45
43 i don't know
i have no idea
what is it um so i don't know i get like
like i feel like we should just be
giving women all the information so i'm
never gonna like like this is why they
say i hate women because i like bring up
these stats where if you sleep with more
people
and like your chances of a happy
marriage goes down and i don't enjoy
this eva i'm not a virgin i wish i was
like that's what i'm saying like i don't
enjoy
this isn't fun for me either but like i
feel like if i was younger and i had all
the information i could have made like
different decisions you know
yeah i feel like just in general there
needs to be more sex education
because even for like guys like
sex education in america or maybe it's
not just america maybe just our schools
but it sucks
i don't believe in sex education in
schools
i know this is i don't i'm not saying in
school it's just in general yeah well i
think i've learned all the sex education
i learned it wasn't mom and dad it
wasn't from schools it was from social
media or people in school who learned it
from social media like and i think porn
has like ruined a generation
yeah did you know you could have a porn
addiction yeah a lot of guys that's so
sick a lot of guys do it's a big thing
it's like a big problem
yeah like i've i actually have never
i've only watched porn once
and it was because some guy i told him i
never watched porn i was in the lobby of
my dorm in college
i swear to god and he was like i need to
show it to you and i'm like oh no that's
okay
oh no let me let me show come here i
have a premium account and i'm like oh
no you really don't
that's the only time
because i feel like i'd rather keep like
doors closed
does that make sense
yeah like i'd rather like
i don't know i don't want to mess with
that stuff
i don't agree with keeping like okay
porn is different but i don't care i
don't agree with keeping things behind
closed doors like like i think that sex
should be openly talked about more
you want to talk about sex with mom and
dad
right now it seems weird but i think
that if we would have grown up in a
society where it's not weird to talk
about sex
like some of my friends literally talk
about sex with their parents like it's
like and they have good relationships
with their parents because of it because
they have that type of relationship i'm
not saying i want to like talk about
like the intimate details but i don't
want to be afraid to like
like you know
not just like sex not like sex even just
like relationships and like things like
that i just think i think that
i don't ever like whenever people say we
should be more open about sex what'd
they say they both got black footage
stop guys
okay
when they say like
we should be more open about sex all the
people that say that make it weird
like they make it to the point where
they're like let's teach guys how to
like make a girls finish and like i
don't think that i'm not talking about
that i just mean like stop making it
weird to talk about in general yeah
because people like it's like if we're
not in the 1800s anymore people can have
sex without being in a marriage they can
have whatever yeah but you don't think
it's i think it's so normal like you see
sex everywhere
yeah that's what i'm saying and yet
people still act like it's a big deal
maybe i don't i don't i think that's
just in our circles i don't think that's
like the world
maybe it's just a private school yeah no
i think it's a private school thing
because
people talk about sex like i think
a little too much
i just feel like they talk about sex on
social media but like in real life
do you think social media is real
i don't even know at this point i mean
like clearly it is but like
you have a different like you're a
different person on social media
like everybody like it's not
like people aren't real on social media
like you think it's weird how like
people can look like completely
different on social media than they do
in real life
i think it's i think it's sad almost how
easy it is
yeah like especially your generation
edits pictures a lot don't they
my friends don't but yeah they do
like i know so oh my god there's so many
bad photos there's this one girl i saw
her photo on instagram i was like that's
not real and i zoomed in i'm like why
are the stairs crooked
is that embarrassing to get caught
editing a picture it's so embarrassing
and i also think it's like everybody
knows it's fake what's even the point
behind it yeah
no well and
there's some pictures i don't even
recognize
that the person see that's what i i'm
totally against photoshopping yourself
and putting it on social media like the
two pictures that i have posted on
instagram are
those are beautiful pictures yeah like
they're not photoshopped they're just
photoshoots i mean maybe she does
photoshop them i don't know she probably
like makes it a little better but yeah
but but even if it's like i die not if
there is photoshop in there i don't know
about it yeah and just like i think it's
it's so bad some of the people's
instagrams are so bad with photoshop
it's just i think that's more
embarrassing than if they would have
just posted it without it
i agree
i agree like
i think it's better to just light makeup
maybe light
light retouch filter but like it's just
gotten so far where i'm like
i always get that i look better
in person than i do in photos
and you know what's crazy in high school
i got the opposite comment
like in high school i think people
thought i looked better in photos than i
did in person
and i think it's because now like people
are so edited
like that photogenic just doesn't do as
much i'm also just against constantly
posting your life on social media
what about me no because like even you
like no i just mean like
like
you do it but you do it for a living
like there's a difference like you
and i just mean like in the sense of oh
you always join me for free
i mean yeah but i mean there's so many
people that could just post every little
thing on like their snapchat stories or
on instagram i'm like i have two posts
on instagram they're almost exactly a
year apart and before that i didn't like
like i used to post a bunch when i was a
kid but it's just like honestly it's
embarrassing to post so much like stupid
things like people
and people are not paying attention to
it people don't want your constant life
updates like i'm sorry nobody's the main
character
like people like to think they are
no that's the thing that's the thing our
society has become so like me centric
like everything's about me me me and
like they don't think about other people
and that's that's the hardest thing
about like
even just like growing up like i feel
like if i have to ask any of my siblings
like any of you guys to show up to
anything you guys will all show up
one or two of you might show up late
[Music]
don't point at me no i'm not that would
be gabrielle
i will be there 30 minutes early like i
always am but that's what i'm saying
like but that's so especially as you get
older you're going to see that is so
uncommon like people are so unreliable
it's like nuts no i i already see that
with a lot of people because even
getting people to show up to my show
like it's frustrating when i'll like
plan a whole show get a thumbnail like
do all this [ __ ] just for them not to
show up
or cancel like two hours before
yeah no
i even see that now a lot of people like
like i'm friends with that's the thing
is that i'm a very reliable person like
if you asked me to be somewhere i will
be there because like mom dad they were
always late for me so it's just like a
thing now is that i absolutely hate
canceling last minute not keeping people
updated on like what your plans are for
the day i
i understand like
like i
hated being in the dark in our family
especially because like you don't
understand how much i was in the dark
because being the second youngest people
constantly looked at you like you were
the second youngest i'm like all you
people are trying to hide the
information i already know
like you guys act like i don't sit
outside the door and listen
you used to out of what door
oh no it was so easy did you know that
if mom and dad are just like like
arguing in like the laundromat like
they're talking in the laundry room you
can literally go in amelia's room lay
your ear on the floor and hear
everything crisp as day
my nosy ass wishes i knew this years ago
yeah or you can simply just sit in the
bathroom open the laundry shoot and
listen like if the the doors are open
downstairs
and they always talked in the laundry
room and they would close the laundry
room door so you'd know not to go in
there or they would go in their room
which literally just sit outside the
door and you can hear when they start
walking towards the door to leave
or in dad's office never catch you
no
like
i'm good at my jobs in dad's office you
just sit on the stairs literally right
outside dad's office you can hear
everything or you go in the old au pair
room what's the craziest thing you've
listened to
i'm not gonna say that no can you tell
me later i can i can type it out and i
can text it to me
i'm so nosy i wish i knew this years ago
i never would have thought of that
oh
yeah okay yeah but then everyone knew
that later
what else anything else did you ever
find out what about me anything about me
not really
i don't really i don't think like the
most i've ever gotten from mom is that
she trusts me more than you
but like that that was like she told me
that directly also this is that when i
was dating one year
no that was like right before i left
for the airport like like she was
dropping me off to direct places yeah i
trust you more than me too
not just directing what the whatever mom
they got only fanned i'm kidding
oh my gosh guys she's underage you
weirdos
only for like six more days um stop it
well actually
exactly seven days
yeah
oh my gosh okay you know what else is
weird like
parasocial relationships you know what
that is
when people feel like they know you that
don't
because they see me online you know i
mean
yeah so be like random people come up to
me and act like they know me and i'm
like i don't know you at all
yeah that's kind of just like
like in school too people it's like when
people we were kids and people would
always assume we had such a perfect life
because we had so much money
i'm just like you simply do not know
anything that happens
yeah well or people like
have you noticed people get jealous and
kind of her
i don't know if it was just me but i
felt like a lot of mom and dad's like
like friends
would be kind of waiting for stuff to go
wrong
yeah and like i feel almost like preying
on their downfall a little bit
i feel like
honestly dad has friends but mom not so
much like mom has like a few people here
and there
like that's one thing that i'm realizing
more and more with like getting older is
that my friend's parents have friends
like they go out with their friends for
like girls and stuff and mom just
doesn't do that and i think that's then
i remember her telling us about like
when she moved into the big house and
when she got like when she said she lost
all her friends i just think that she
may not trust getting new friends
because all her friends left her when
she gained money no that's that's what
the the top is lonely and people are
jealous like yeah even even like i've
lost like i told you i lost friends with
this
yeah
which is it's unfortunate and i think
it's the same concept with like
like growing up too i was so picky about
my friends like even you know i
literally like two friends growing up
because like people constantly try using
you for money
oh my gosh i would have so many times
where i thought i was friends with
someone and they were just like using
me
for our house no yeah that's what i mean
like that's that's why i stopped being
friends with haley's because she got so
greedy for what like like we started
like uh sophomore year she wanted to
throw a homecoming after party and she
couldn't at her house i was like oh yeah
like it's fine like i've been friends
with you for nine years like i trust you
and then she didn't want to come to the
party that she threw
she came for two minutes and left and
that was the day i was like i'm done
with you
i had a friend do you remember anthony
yeah do you remember what happened with
him no so anthony i i was like in love
with him in high school
um the one one white guy i had a crush
on
just kidding i was actually
had a big crush anyways anyways um so he
um
when we were in high school we were like
best friends i mean i had a crush on him
but he like kind of friend zoned me but
it was fine because like honestly i just
like
you know what i mean like you've ever
had a guy that like
even if he friend zones you like he's so
cool like he would just be his friend
it's fine yeah that makes sense anyways
but he i think he kind of knew so he
kind of like took advantage of me a
little bit
so in high school
right before this all happened do you
remember the party i threw
were you no i'm sure i was around but
oh so you don't know this story at all
probably not yeah i don't really pay
attention to the older siblings this is
like there's a cut right in between adam
and gabrielle
okay this is the one like the one thing
i got in trouble for in high school so
when
i was home alone for over a month my
junior year of high school
i didn't do anything
a month eva
you guys all went on vacation i had
volleyball
you know all the other siblings would
have been throwing hella parties
oh yeah drink i didn't i think i drank
one time in that month
that was it and it was like with one
other girl and i thought i was so
badass
oh wait no i didn't because my junior
year i didn't even drink i drank my
first time anyways
oh no no no i did that was the first
summer i drank okay
senior year
i decide mom and dad are gone i've been
so good
i've been doing i did nothing all of
high school
i'm about to go to college i'm gonna
throw a party
and it wasn't a big party eva it was
like 20 people
but mom and dad didn't know makes sense
yeah
um this was a long time ago so i like
it's a little hazy and i know i'm
butchering the story but basically the
20 people came over and there was a
couple things that went wrong okay one
someone went into mom and dad's bathtub
that was broken
these two girls decided to take a bath
at the party i don't know why one girl
puked in someone's room on the carpet on
the floor like like little things stuff
that could be i didn't know the bathtub
was actually a big thing it ruined the
ceiling but that
you know i mean like that could be lied
i could just say i took a bat does that
make sense yeah so
whatever
um
clean up everything spent hours cleaning
up all this stuff
everyone's gone i think i got away with
it
until a couple days later
um
dad comes back
and he says
why
he says like i know you threw a party i
know it had to have been a rage or did
and i'm like that's so weird like why
we cleaned everything up i took out the
trash all like i didn't i took the trash
to like the
mom and dad's office okay
and
he said there's beer
cans a whole bag full of beer cans and i
thought it was so weird because we
didn't drink beer like i've never been a
beer drinker i didn't buy beer for
people
[Music]
so what happened was i
joined you guys on vacation
so like then when after i threw the
party i left anthony knew i was leaving
oh so he used to he came back
and threw parties at the house after i
left
man's bold yeah and so
and then they all like lied to me about
it after
and tried to like make me think i was
like nuts
oh
yeah that's crazy and also just shows
how easy it is to get to our house
though yeah and don't put that on there
but then on top of that though like they
he also was starting to say things to me
like like acting in tight because he
knew mom and dad had a food card for me
and he would act like entitled to it
like it was like his money
yeah like oh i know your parents pay for
that like
and i'm like well it's still not yours
like they pay for it for me
yeah it's also like you're their child
and like that's
that was like the first
big experience i had with someone just
like using me for my parents stuff
because i thought we were like best
friends and we kind of were but
yeah after that i like
never really talked to him again
yeah now i think that the
see i've never had people like using it
like in that sense i just had like
people do little things like because
freshman year obviously like it's a new
school like you want to make friends
with new people
and
i just
i don't know i think the biggest thing i
had was
like just
honestly probably my volleyball coach
last year
oh that was crazy no because she was
first off she was a grown-ass woman like
i'm just like you're like and then oh
man she was so hype over here don't tell
them what happened because they don't
know the story this yeah woman tried to
bamboozle my little sister she did
bamboozle me i never got my money back
you're never gonna i never got my money
back
no so
she because she um
like i play volleyball and we had to do
a senior night so senior night's like
the last home game for the seniors at
the school
and she insisted we all hand tied make
those tie blankets which are expensive
to make yourself like when you have to
make a bunch of them they're expensive
to make and we need to make like 12 of
them
the entire varsity was seniors like all
the seniors left and they ordered fabric
like in bulk online so it was cheaper it
was like 150 bucks by this bulk fabric
and then it didn't get there on time and
then the girl who was like the like
manager i guess on our team of the
senior night texted me being like hey
eva will you be able to go pick up the
fabric for me
because it didn't get here in time and i
was like oh yeah sure like that's no
problem cause like i'll go pick it up
like of course i'm gonna get paid back
for it because we'll just return the
other fabric and i'll get paid back and
i went there and i spent like three
hundred dollars on fabric because we
didn't order in bulk goodbye to joanne's
and then whatever it worked out fine we
were one blanket short but we just
bought a cheap blanket at the dollar
tree like we were like whatever we we
tried our best
and then
we like they came over like they met one
yay two and then we had pizza like i i
hosted the whole thing for us to make
all these baskets for all these girls
and then they left and then i get a text
later that day
from coach dawn which i honestly don't
care i'm saying her name she can get
cancelled
i don't think they'll be able to find
her i know i don't even know see nuts
i don't even know her first name
this [ __ ]
keep going keep going um but so i was
like yeah like well um
yeah so like then she texts me and she
very like i don't know why she decided
to text me because honestly if she
hadn't texted me this whole thing
probably wouldn't have been like i
probably would have forgotten about the
fact that she like needed like i need
money from her
but she texted me knowing she definitely
knew that i paid for the fabric because
she would have texted kate saying did
everything go well but she texted me and
you're like did everything go well did
you guys get them all done i was like oh
yeah like we were one blanket short but
it's fine oh yeah just so you know i had
to buy the fabric
um like just you know i had to buy the
fabric and then she was like oh well
thank you so much for doing that that
was so kind of you and like that was the
text and i was like what do you mean
that was so kind of me like that's not a
donation like i want my money back and i
texted her like this whole long
paragraph of being like i do like i get
it whatever and this is after mom just
spent like 1200 buying the school new
volleyballs
so this [ __ ] and mom offered to buy
them new jerseys too so like she knew
mom dad had money and she knew it was
like i was i was so done with like with
this woman and you never got your money
back no it was a two week long thing i
went to our athletic director and i said
this isn't right and he's like i like i
want to help you but there's literally
nothing i can do
why
they look oh my god that makes me so mad
i wanted them to take it out of like the
salary that she gets paid at the end of
the season because honestly like it's my
money that she owes me
and then and not only that she said she
said that she wasn't going to cancel the
fabric because she wanted to use it for
the seniors this year which they didn't
end up using it i don't know where the
fabric is but
yeah oh my god
that makes me so mad it wasn't mom and
dad's money it was mine
did mom and dad give you the money i
think mom did but even if like that no
that is so ridiculous
that's that's like literally prime
example of taking advantage of a
freaking like a child and not only that
then oh my no it was so bad after all
this went down
and like it was like it was just like it
was the season was ending like it was
fine the seniors needed a police to have
senior nights they couldn't do it at the
school or like a party
no they needed a place to have a party
for see the seniors because the school
wasn't going to do its coveted
restrictions so coach asked kate who's
the girl who would like was like she's
in my grade to ask me saying hey do you
think the davises will let me use their
house oh even though i told them no
right [ __ ] those oh no kate told me kate
told me that
like coach asked her she's like i'm just
not comfortable asking you to do that
because you're not even on the team i
was like yeah i'm not going to do it on
the team no
she just wanted to use the house
you weren't on the team well buying the
fabric if you weren't on the team no the
junior set up you know how the juniors
no but she wanted the senior team's
party at my house and i was just like
why would we i do that for you
oh my god that
[ __ ] that [ __ ] like she was soap and
then i i let her have the athletic
director for letting that happen no
people edward catholic high school
no pj can honestly die for that but then
just to be petty i was like oh yeah but
we can do the junior party here like we
can have the junior volleyball team
there and like of course dawn came
whatever but um so we had like the
junior party there and then she gave
awards to all of the girls in the
volleyball team for like random [ __ ] was
like passing or serving something except
for me and i was like you're such a
[ __ ] wait she gave everyone every
single person at your house my house got
an award except for me and i was like
what the [ __ ] is this the audacity
of these people but this is the [ __ ]
like you literally have to deal with
like no one is constantly complaining
because i don't got college debt
so this is i'm okay with these problems
but like
people
like even even the teacher
that tried to fail me in high school
yeah do you think she would have done
that if we weren't if we weren't who we
are
she wouldn't even like attempted to no
and that's the that's the thing people
don't like our family sometimes because
we just like don't care about the rules
yeah no that's yeah like like and i
agree like i'm sorry if i'm getting good
grades and i'm passing my classes it is
not your damn business where i am if my
mom signs off on it
go you're not my parent like
what if i was home school
we do get
no we get away with a lot though that's
like not like you know what's fun
threatening to sue people in meaning
did you know mrs schimke sued mom and
dad for what the teacher that i got
fired saying that it was like character
defamation or whatever like saying like
or like like something like saying that
like i lied that was what happened with
that she lost the case no no i mean like
i forgot that happened i remember mom
telling me about it but i was so young
like oh no okay so um in eighth grade
mrs schimke like and like i was just
gonna stick out and wait at the end of
the year but i was like no this lady
like literally needs to go
not only was she so sexist towards the
girls like she literally like and she
also let the boys like go into the girls
locker room while they were like girls
were changing to like put away mats and
like the girls could have put them away
while we were like like the mats went in
the back of the state catherine's like
the girls could just put them away like
it doesn't need to be something that the
guys do and then she would oh my gosh
she made fun of girls for like being
like too big or too skinny like so often
and like this one girl um
oh my god who is she making fun of i
don't even know who she's making fun of
but like we were like doing hockey or
something like that and she was like oh
yeah no you can't be the goalie because
you're too skinny like like you need to
put some meat on the bones or like just
like telling like people that they need
to like go exercise it was like it was
like little things she would do here and
there but it's just like weird from a
teacher yeah and like she wasn't she
wasn't like and she was just like like
she was like a manly woman like nothing
wrong with it but it was like like in a
gross way oh okay
but i was like whatever and then she
would also swear in front of like little
preschoolers you know like st catherine
does pre-k or whatever to the point that
my one my mass buddy because you know
like eighth graders walked down their
mass but literally came up to me yelled
[ __ ] and i was like do you know what
that means she's like no i was like
don't say that she's like i was like
where'd you learn that she's like mrs
shimke was telling our class that i was
like like why are you doing this
like it's like no she whatever and then
she would specifically tell our class in
other classes to not be misbehaved when
the principal is sitting in on classes
so that she doesn't get in trouble
because she has to put on her best
behavior so so do we
and i was just like like what is this so
then you got her fired no then me and
monica wrote a we wrote a three-page
letter
to this principal saying all of this
stuff saying like and the same thing
with like she would call the boy studs
which if you know the meaning of stud it
literally means a sexually attractive
male mm-hmm
like and i'm just like this is so gross
like we're in eighth grade we're 13 14
guys like this is like not appropriate
right
and so me and monica wrote this long ass
letter
like um
there were so many things to it
but stuff like that
like it was like we told her like the
swearing and like the like misbehaving
and like whatever and that we just
thought like we and we didn't say to get
her fire we just said that we wanted
somebody to look into the situation
because it is inappropriate
to continue and monica did an amazing
job writing this like monica should be a
writer because she's genuinely like
amazing at it but um
and we we turned it into school on
friday like right before like when we
were walking out for the weekend we
pulled it up said can you give this to
me to mrs um
who's the principal i can't remember
um and then she was like the
late lady in the office was like yeah
she's now time to give it to her on
monday well monday we walk into school
there's rumors going around but mrs jim
keem being like what's going on what's
going on we everybody saw her walk in
and then leave later in the day and then
at the end of the day they sent out an
email saying that the diocese of
rockford has collectively agreed it's in
the best interest to
dismiss mrs schimke effective
immediately
but like all the kids are like guys this
is your fault i'm like okay one letter
is not gonna get her fire like there
obviously had to be because i know for a
fact there were multiple parent
complaints about her
and this was just like
the other students were mad because the
boys probably liked her the boys loved
her they were upset they literally
talked about this still and i'm like
guys it's been like five years like can
we just drop it
oh
so then you were like the scapegoat and
that's why you're getting you're getting
like bullied over it yeah like no
literally because then i had a
pre-planned trip before any of this to
go to the dominican with you and mom
that's when it was happening it happened
literally like the week before so then
when i left for the dominican everybody
said that i was so ashamed of what i did
i fled the country and like guys
like that's a little bit of an
overreaction we had we had a vacation
like this like the vacation was planned
for a while before this guys like it
wasn't like it wasn't you guys oh we
made two dollars did we oh i missed it
pearly sister's blanket i'd be covering
for these girls
i think this is the same person oh my
gosh but yeah and then oh no honestly i
was so glad i was the scapegoat because
monica was like like she like wrote the
letter like this whole thing was my idea
but monica wrote the letter and i was so
glad that people didn't blame monica
because i would have felt so bad if
monica was getting bullied for something
that was completely my idea
yeah
like i was i was honestly so glad that's
the thing about being in davis we will
complain
no we will
we're not afraid to do it we will be we
will get the manager
the dice he's a rock bird we'd be firing
folks
honestly that was funny
two dollars from the
maybe firing people
[Laughter]
no okay so the other thing um
trying to think no because
when i was in high school i just like
it's funny miss i'm gonna put your name
out there mrs
loy oh my god
bro this lady oh my god
because this is another thing my parents
will not put up with you bullying
children and there's so many people in
schools that like are so excited to get
power for the first time in their life
no seriously it's like it's like really
a problem like you're the principal of a
high school like
down carrot let me read you the email
that they my school sent out
about girls wearing skirts that are too
short okay
like no it's because they seriously like
it's so bad where is it school uniforms
okay um
we have tried to tried our best to show
grace and understanding but we have an
issue that needs your assistance many of
the skirts that our female students are
wearing quite honestly are way too short
we will continue to issue detentions for
skirts being too short but in the
meantime we need to you need to address
this at home but also if they if they
issue a detention you just get a
detention they don't tell you your
skirt's too short ahead of time
why don't
you
some of the i'm sorry some of the high
schoolers need to be pulling their
some of them do i'm not disagreeing with
that but like i get to i've gotten a
detention from my script before too and
my screw is literally like i literally
measured it two inches above my knees
and like that's that's i was like i
don't even know what i need to do
anymore and like there's one girl who
walks around her i can literally see her
spandex and she's never got an attention
for it before i'm like this is honestly
just like what the [ __ ]
like um
if your daughter's skirt is more than
two inches above the knee it will need
to be lengthened next week which would
be the perfect time for those
alterations to be made in
in this case this is not results we will
be we will move
we will make the move to require uniform
pants for all students male and female
we have already been in contact with
lanzens to discuss the options for our
uniform pants for both male and female
students while we do not want to have to
make this change we will just hope they
should continue to respect an email more
that just said stop being [ __ ]
literally
um this potential change to the dress
code is not a punishment it is a
solution to a problem that has harmed
relations between students teachers and
administrators enforcing the dress code
surrounding skirt length is it
distracting and unproductive for
everyone attending policy is a practical
solution to a problem that gets more
attention than is justified which nobody
literally nobody cares except for the
like administration
and it's so like i'm just like we're at
the point where like the girls who are
way too short i get it but like some
girls i'm just like it's fine nobody
cares it's not distracting to any
students like for god's sakes we're
wearing a [ __ ] skirt like i might as
well just do like below the knees i
think that would just help
it might not happen i honestly don't
think anybody would follow it
yeah they're going to get pants
yeah and honestly i don't care like i'm
getting out but um what was i going to
tell you
no but it was crazy because even when i
was in high school like they were so
butthurt when i would miss school
because our family
we're not a family of karen's we're a
family of people that don't like karen's
bully us
honestly that's like that's what we do
no mom's karen do you think mom's a kid
karen she's 100 i care run i don't think
so like when was she karen
like little things
it's like like i can't tell you like off
the top of my head but mom like she does
complain about
things are not really needed
maybe mom's a little karen but i don't
know because most of the [ __ ] i've seen
mom complain about i'm like i would
complain about that too
no i'd say when we were younger she
wasn't she just like stood up and now
it's like
more caring yeah it's the last thing she
complained about
i don't even know i haven't spent a lot
of time recently i know that a lot of
the time during covid
she
like
like i'm not gonna force her to put on a
mask but like if somebody's telling her
to put on a mask she would honestly
maybe not even care just like a baby
about it like it's not that hard to wear
a mask
like i get not wanting to and it may be
uncomfortable but like if i can wear a
mask perfectly like normally like how
you're correctly supposed to during
volleyball mom can wear one while
sitting on a plane oh my god and she was
so
defensive over and like oh actually i do
she was annoying about the math and i'm
just like like she would rather get in a
screaming match with someone that just
wear a mask yeah and i'm just like
itched for once she like told the
airlines that she had uh asthma
and i'm just like
it was just it was so much unnecessary
work to put a piece of cloth over your
face
yeah i could see that
i don't know i just feel like in
high school like
my administration was so
upper [ __ ] about everything you ever
notice okay do you think some teachers
abuse their power and like if people saw
what went on in their classroom like
they would not have a job oh yeah a
hundred percent like why was mrs
garrigan showing you guys cnn
i loved mrs garrick i'm sorry that is
she did the kids news version though it
doesn't matter cnn is so biased
like like i'm saying i think it'd be
inappropriate for someone to show fox
news
yeah like baby like like it's not your
job to politicize children like what the
[ __ ] are you doing
no and it's a lot of the things that
like teachers pick and choose what they
want to get students in trouble for like
a lot like my friend maddie just got she
almost got suspended actually for saying
[ __ ] class
because she was talking about our one
teacher who like personally i like her
teaching style but like not everybody's
the same
and
maddie is a straight a student like 4.0
gpa like she's an amazing student but
that class she ended with a dn because
that's teacher like she's not a good
teacher for a lot of students like just
like it's not a common teaching style it
goes quick whatever i personally like it
a lot of students don't
but um maddie didn't even say [ __ ] to
the teacher she always she said is that
the teacher's name and she said she's
just not a good [ __ ] teacher
and
maddie almost got suspended for it
meanwhile suspension suspended i mean
that for that meanwhile a kid in my
class openly says the n-word he's white
openly says the n-word multiple times
and all she says is frank stop
okay ma'am that's an opinion that's the
thing like
i hate i hate oh my gosh school politics
it was so funny when i went back to get
you know who fired from gabrielle's
school yeah
um
i like mrs loy was trying to like talk
to me
and like me have me meet with her and i
was like i would literally rather die
than meet with you like no mrs shimkey
set up a meet up too
after i got her fired she set up a meet
up and had
jacob breyer tell which yeah you can
cancel him to [ __ ] hate him had him
tell all the class where
they were meeting
and they met like in spring hill mall
and like half the kids like all the boys
showed up and like saw her like hi
whatever whatever first not only do i
think it's inappropriate that the
parents just took their stuff
no it's so weird and i had haley i
literally said haley you're going and
you're recording this and she didn't we
literally have on recording mrs shimkey
saying oh yeah students will say
anything of you like they can write a
letter or say something on social media
but sit them right down in front of you
and they won't say [ __ ] now let me just
throw her into the ocean like see how
she feels about that now i'm like what
the [ __ ] are we talking about now like
you got beat up by a 14 year old you're
just mad
not even 14 i was 13.
i was like you're just mad that you got
beat by a 13 year old i think who did i
i'm trying to think if i ever had beef
in middle school with any teachers
i don't think so i think it was just mrs
lloyd in high school but for those of
you that don't know this teacher tried
to um basically
fail me even though i had a high i don't
know what i had i had a bna in her class
and she tried to give me a zero
for everything i missed in a week
because my mom called me in and said i
was sick but we were in florida on vacay
and like let me tell you it was a fun
vacay so worth it
and my mom's response is like it's not
your damn business where i take my kids
if they're passing
and it was also a personal vendetta
because i always missed her class
because i'm smart
and i'm good at english
so i just would never go
because i wanted to sleep and i was in
two sports they were both travel
and
i was i at my prac my school was half
hour away sports were 45 minutes away
like i was just exhausted
and my markers are in the wrong
direction too like sky high oh
everything's so far so far so far and
like i you know how it is like you're
just tired i wasn't doing anything no
especially like right now that's kind of
me except for i'm not doing like like i
did regional this year just because i
literally think i would kill myself if i
had to do
jl because it's too much travel yeah but
then mrs loy like it was one this was so
inappropriate one
i won
because mom and dad threatened to sue
them and
yeah because you can't just fail me
because you feel like it
like
i'm sorry you don't have the legal right
to do that no she doesn't
and then um
two
um she told me i would never make it or
do anything in college
and it was funny because i graduated a
double major i played three sports
and i actually got away with more
shenanigans in college i think that's
another thing growing up though is that
people assume that because we have money
we don't work hard oh my god we we work
really hard no i think our family some
of them like hardest like not to like
brag about myself either but like i'm a
busy [ __ ] person
and i work a job and i have a horse that
i consistently made like having a horse
is a lot of work that's one thing that
like
the only one
there's one or two but even even our
lazy siblings like honestly work harder
than most people no that's what i mean
like like sometimes adam can be lazy but
adam's adam like when he's doing like
work he's a hard-working person and i
don't like adam so that's saying a lot
adam works at if i had to bet on anyone
in our family like becoming a
millionaire i would bet on adam like
like really i'd bet on chazz chad's as
smart as [ __ ] too yeah he's gonna be a
cop i just don't think chess wants to do
like
he didn't want to be a millionaire but
i'm just saying that like
like chaz is a hard worker like we're
doing by hardworking people and like
smart like trash could honestly do a lot
yeah he could austin's gonna be really
successful like he already is really
successful but he's going to look i just
think adam is the most like
like to become really rich you have to
have a lot of risk
yeah is he is that's what i'm saying
like i think that's why i said if i had
to bet on anyone it'd be adam it doesn't
mean like he's the smartest or the most
competent it's just like willing
yeah adam's just the most bold so like
i'm i'm i won't take as many risks as
adam well it's not my personality yeah
and i'm pretty i take a lot of risks
like this whole show is a freaking risk
moving to london but like adam
would put his life savings into
something i don't i guess i kind of did
but not
i don't know to the extent um
pearl's a-hole the teachers were right
up in me
[Music]
okay
y'all be weird sometimes
um
okay
well i think this was a fun talk
you wanna do it again tomorrow
i guess
you guys like these talks i think
they're kind of fun i'd be taking risks
[Music]
who is this
i'd be taking risks adam thank you so
thank you for the one two three four
five six eight dollars eight dollars and
i get to take home four of it so you
could say i'm living large
does that mean i get two
what do you want
let me get paid for being on here
look people ask me and i'm like you
realize how little money i made
i mean this was just like what an hour
you made
four dollars yeah well we'll see
sometimes clips
yeah like then you make then you clip it
it's
it'll be more than eight dollars but not
much more
okay guys um
thank you for tuning in today
hit the subscribe button if you don't
subscribe already also
if you guys like this format of chats
i think i want to bring in like other
people with like different opinions
um and like one-on-one because
i don't know i kind of like the idea of
having different types of talks on this
channel not just like a live show
like a mix of this public interviews
two more people one who grew up in like
really lower class i want to grow up in
middle class and then talk to them
because you were up class
oh that that'd be interesting actually
and i'll probably get like lighting up
here next time so it's a little better
um but yeah don't forget to subscribe
i'm gonna go turn it off because it's
over there
but love you